IN SALT LAKE CITY, YOU CANNOT GO
WRONG, YOU WILL LOVE IT.
OBVIOUSLY, I LIKE HAMBURGERS
PAIRED WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE ARE WITNESSING WHAT IS A
LOGICAL, MAJOR SHIFT IN AMERICAN
POLITICS.
LIKE YOU'VE NEVER SEEN.
THE NEW FAR LEFT EXTREME
SOCIALIST DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY
ARE HITTING NEW LEVELS OF
RADICALISM.
MUELLER DIDN'T DELIVER ON THEIR
COLLUSION FANTASY, AND BY THE
WAY, RUSH WAS GREAT EARLIER
TONIGHT WHEN HE SAID "OH,
HILLARY NEEDS TO BE IN JAIL AND
INDICTED, IF YOU DID WHAT SHE
DID, YOU WOULD BE IN JAIL.
THE TRUMP AGENDA SUCCEEDING,
THAT IS DRIVING THEM OFF THE
RAILS.
IT WAS ON FULL DISPLAY LAST
NIGHT.
FAKE NEWS CNN PUT THE 2020
DEMOCRATS ON STAGE ONE AFTER
ANOTHER, HOUR AFTER HOUR OF
HARD-CORE SOCIALISM, ARE THEY
COMPLETELY TRIED TO OUT
SOCIALIST OF THE OTHER SOCIALIST
ON STAGE, IMPEACHMENT OF TRUMP,
OPEN BORDERS, GUNS, OPPRESSIVE
TAXES, AND OF COURSE, YES,
REDISTRIBUTION AND THE GREEN NEW
DEAL, WHERE CRAZY BERNIE SANDERS
WAS CONFRONTED ABOUT THE REAL
FAILURES OF SOCIALISM THROUGHOUT
HISTORY.
WHY WOULD WE NOT LEARN FROM
HISTORY?
AGAIN, FROM A WOMAN WHOSE FAMILY
ACTUALLY FLED THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION IN 1979 CARE TAKE A
LOOK.
>> MY FATHER'S FAMILY LEFT
RUSSIA IN 1979 FLEEING FROM SOME
OF THE SAME SOCIALIST POLICIES
YOU SEEM EAGER TO IMPLEMENT IN
THIS COUNTRY.
MY QUESTION IS, HOW DO YOU
RECTIFY YOUR NOTION OF
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISM WITH THE
FAILURE OF SOCIALISM IN
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE TRIED IT?
>> YOUR ASSUMPTION THAT I
SUPPORTED OR BELIEVED IN
AUTHORITARIAN COMMUNISM THAT
EXISTED WITHIN THE SOVIET      S
EXISTED WITHIN THE SOVIET      V
EXISTED WITHIN THE SOVIET      N
EXISTED WITHIN THE SOVIET      O
EXISTED WITHIN THE SOVIET      ,
I OPPOSED IT.
WHAT DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISM MEANS
TO ME AS WE EXPAND MEDICARE, WE
PROVIDE EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL AMERICANS, WE REBUILD
CUMBERLAND INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN OTHER WORDS, GOVERNMENT
SERVES THE NEEDS OF ALL PEOPLE,
RATHER THAN JUST WEALTHY
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTORS.
>> Sean: OF COURSE, BERNIE,
THE SOCIALIST, DIDN'T HAVE AN
ANSWER, BECAUSE EVERYWHERE HIS
IDEAS, HIS UTOPIA IS PUT IN
PLACE, THEY ALWAYS FAIL.
KEEP YOUR DOCTOR, KEEP YOUR
PLAN, SAVE MONEY SCARED EVERYONE
LOST DOCTORS, PLANS, ONLY ONE
CHOICE, EVERYONE PAID MORE AND
IT GOT WORSE, BECAUSE SANDERS IS
BACKING THE RIGHT FOR ALL FELONS
TO VOTE.
PRISONERS, MURDERERS, YES, EVEN
TERRORIST LIKE THE BOSTON
BOMBERS.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU HAVE SAID THAT YOU WILL
BE PEOPLE WITH FELONY RECORDS
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO VOTE WHILE
IN PRISON.
IT DOES THIS MEAN YOU WOULD
SUPPORT AND FRANCHISING PEOPLE
THE BOSTON MARATHON BOMBER AND
CONVICTED TERRORIST AND MURDERE
MURDERER?
>> I THINK THE RIGHT TO VOTE IS
INHERENT TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
YES, EVEN FOR TERRIBLE PEOPLE.
SO I BELIEVE PEOPLE COMMIT
CRIMES, THEY PAY THE PRICE.
THEY GOT OUT OF JAIL, I BELIEVE
THEY CERTAINLY SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE, BUT I DO BELIEVE
EVEN IF THEY ARE IN JAIL, THEY
ARE PAYING THEIR PRICE TO
SOCIETY, BUT THAT SHOULD NOT
TAKE AWAY THEIR INHERENT
AMERICAN RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE IN
OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Sean: SHOCKING, BERNIE
WANTS TO TAKE MORE OF YOUR
HARD-EARNED MONEY, RAISE YOUR
TAXES, ELIMINATE ALL PRIVATE
HEALTH INSURANCE.
YOU ONLY GET THE GOVERNMENT
VERSION, GOOD LUCK WITH THAT.
GET RID OF ALL FOSSIL FUELS, GET
RID OF THE COMBUSTION ENGINE, WE
WILL LET SEX OFFENDERS,
MURDERERS, TERRORISTS, VOTE FROM
PRISON.
WHAT A PLAN FOR AMERICA'S
FUTURE, AND THAT IS ONLY ONE
CANDIDATE.
LOOK AT KAMALA HARRIS, TOOK EVEN
HER BIG GOVERNMENT AGENDA EVEN
FURTHER.
CALIFORNIA SENATOR RAMPING UP
HER ATTACKS, YEP, ON THE
SECOND AMENDMENT, THINKING WE
DON'T HAVE A CONSTITUTION AND WE
DON'T HAVE COEQUAL BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT.
AMAZING MOMENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE ARE PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., SUPPOSES
LEADERS, WHO HAVE FAILED TO HAVE
THE COURAGE TO REJECT A FALSE
CHOICE, WHICH SUGGESTS YOU ARE
EITHER IN FAVOR OF THE
SECOND AMENDMENT OR YOU WANT TO
TAKE EVERYONE'S GUNS AWAY.
SUPPOSE A LEADERS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., WHO HAVE
FAILED TO HAVE THE COURAGE TO
RECOGNIZE, YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU
WANT TO GO HUNTING, THAT IS
FINE, BUT WE NEED REASONABLE GUN
SAFETY LAWS IN THIS COUNTRY,
STARTING WITH UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND A RENEWAL
OF THE ASSAULT WEAPON BAN.
UPON BEING ELECTED, I WILL GIVE
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS 100
DAYS TO GET THEIR ACT TOGETHER
AND HAVE THE COURAGE TO PASS
REASONABLE GUN SAFETY LAWS, AND
IF THEY FAIL TO DO IT, THAT I
WILL TAKE EXECUTIVE ACTION.
>> Sean: QUICK "HANNITY"
CIVICS LESSON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SENATOR  .
THAT'S NOT HOW OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC WORKS.
OUR GOVERNMENT WORKS.
NO MAGICAL COUNTDOWN CLOCK GIVES
THE PRESIDENT SOLE AUTHORITY TO
ATTACK CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
BECAUSE CONGRESS WILL DO WHAT
YOU WANT.
REMEMBER, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
EMERGENCY DECLARATION, WHILE
WITHIN HIS AUTHORITY,
LEGISLATIVELY, CONSTITUTIONALLY,
ACTING PURSUANT TO A REAL LAW
PUT OUT BY CONGRESS, PASSED BY
CONGRESS TO SECURE THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, GRANTING HIM THE POWER
TO DO SO.
SOMETHING LIKE THE CONSTITUTION
COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
DEMOCRATS, THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT
IT.
LAST NIGHT, DID YOU HEAR
ANYTHING ABOUT SERIOUS EFFORTS
TO KEEP OUR NATION SAFE AND
SECURE?
REMEMBER, TWO YEARS, 4,000 PLUS
HOMICIDES, 30,000
SEXUAL ASSAULTS, 100,000, OH,
YEAH, VIOLENT ASSAULTS BY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT CRIMINALS.
TWO YEARS!
NOW IT WAS JUST THE OPPOSITE
LAST NIGHT.
GOOD OLD MAYOR PETEY, GENIUS
THAT HE IS, TALKING ABOUT
AMNESTY FOR MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T RESPECT OUR
LAWS, OUR CONSTITUTION, OUR
SOVEREIGNTY, AND OUR BORDERS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE IS A BROAD U.S.
CONSENSUS THAT WE NEED TO FIND A
WAY TO PROTECT DREAMERS.
BUT AS YOUR QUESTION BRINGS OUT,
THERE ARE OVER 10 MILLION PEOPLE
WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
IN THIS COUNTRY WHO DON'T FALL
INTO THAT CATEGORY.
ON THE REALITY IS, WE CAN'T HAVE
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM
THAT WORKS UNLESS IT ADDRESSES
THE STATUS FOR THOSE 11 PSALM
MILLION UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS MAKE SURE
THERE IS A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR THEM TOO.
>> Sean: OF COURSE, NO
DEMOCRATIC EVENT WOULD BE
COMPLETE WITHOUT, YES, EVEN MORE
LIES AND CONSPIRACY THEORIES
ABOUT TRUMP AND RUSSIA.
FOUR SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS,
THE FBI NINE MONTH
INVESTIGATION, HOUSE INTEL
INVESTIGATION, SENATE BY
PARTISAN INVESTIGATION AND
ROBERT MUELLER HIMSELF, NO
COLLUSION.
LISTEN TO SENATOR WARREN CALLING
FOR IMPEACHMENT, WITH NO BASIS.
DID SHE READ THE CONSTITUTION?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE TOOLS THAT WE ARE GIVEN
FOR THAT ABILITY IS IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT POLITICS.
THIS IS ABOUT PRINCIPLES.
THIS IS ABOUT WHAT KIND OF A
DEMOCRACY WE HAVE.
IN A DICTATORSHIP, EVERYTHING IN
GOVERNMENT AND REVOLVES AROUND
PROTECTING THE ONE PERSON AT THE
CENTER.
BUT NOT IN OUR DEMOCRACY, AND
NOT UNDER OUR CONSTITUTION.
WE HAVE CHECKS AND BALANCES, AND
WE HAVE TO PROCEED IN A WAY
UNDERSTANDING HISTORY.
>> Sean: SENATOR, WHAT PART OF
COLLUSION DON'T YOU UNDERSTAND?
BY THE WAY, SENATOR, I HAVE
ANOTHER QUESTION: DID
HILLARY CLINTON BREAK THE LAW
UNDER THE ESPIONAGE ACT, TOP
SECRET CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ON
THAT SECRET SERVER?
AND WAS HER INTENT TO OBSTRUCT
JUSTICE WHEN SHE DELETED,
BLEACHED PIT, BUSTED UP DEVICES
WITH HAMMERS, PULLED OUT
SIM CARDS?
WARREN FOLLOWED UP THAT REMARK
WITH MORE TALK ABOUT, YEAH,
HIGHER TAXES.
REMEMBER, SHE WANTS TO LEGISLATE
STEALING COME OVER AFTER YOU PAY
YOUR TAXES, IF YOU HAPPEN TO
HAVE ANY LEFT, SHE WANTS THE
GOVERNMENT TO SAY YOU SAVED TOO
MUCH AND WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK
AND TAKE ANOTHER BITE AT THE
APPLE, AND DON'T FORGET, WHEN
YOU DIE, YOU PAY A BIGGER BITE
OF THE APPLE.
THEY ALWAYS GET THE GOLD IN YOUR
TEETH IF THEY COULD.
GOVERNMENT DEBT AND FORGIVENESS,
FREE COLLEGE, WHO IS GOING TO
PAY FOR ALL OF THIS?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE GOING TO ROLLBACK
STUDENT LOAN DEBT FOR ABOUT 95%
OF STUDENTS WHO HAVE DEBT.
THAT IS PART ONE.
AND PART TWO IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE NEVER GET IN THIS MESS
AGAIN ON STUDENT LOAN DEBT, AND
THAT IS TO MAKE COLLEGE
UNIVERSALLY AVAILABLE, WITH FREE
TUITION AND FEES.
>> Sean: WENT TO THE REST OF
US GET OUR REFUND?
I WROTE FOR TEN YEARS A CHECK
THAT YOU MAKE A PAYMENT, I TOOK
OUT ONE STUDENT LOAN, AND GUESS
WHAT, 5805, WHEN I DIDN'T HAVE
ANY MONEY.
NOT WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS A
PARTY THAT HAS GONE SO FAR LEFT
IT EVEN LOOKS LIKE CRAZY, CREEPY
UNCLE JOE BIDEN IS HAVING COLD
FEET, ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT
TONIGHT, HE AGAIN PUSHED BACK
HIS LAUNCH, WHICH WAS SET FOR
THURSDAY, WON'T DO AN OFFICIAL
CAMPAIGN KICK OFF UNTIL MONDAY,
AND A NEW PIECE OUT IN THE DAILY
MAIL LAYS OUT THE CHAOS
SURROUNDING BIDEN'S 22
"ROLLOUT," RAISING MORE
QUESTIONS ABOUT CREEPY, CRAZY
UNCLE JOE EVEN HAS A PLACE IN TE
UNCLE JOE EVEN HAS A PLACE IN TW
UNCLE JOE EVEN HAS A PLACE IN TD
UNCLE JOE EVEN HAS A PLACE IN TM
UNCLE JOE EVEN HAS A PLACE IN TC
UNCLE JOE EVEN HAS A PLACE IN TA
UNCLE JOE EVEN HAS A PLACE IN TT
UNCLE JOE EVEN HAS A PLACE IN T.
WAIT UNTIL THEY HEAR SOME OF THE
THINGS WE ARE ABOUT TO ADVISE
THEM ON.
THIS IS YOUR NEW
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
REMEMBER, MEDICARE FOR ALL WOULD
TAKE UP MOST OF THE BUDGET FOR
TEN STRAIGHT YEARS.
THAT IS ONE ITEM.
GAS AND OIL, REMEMBER, WE ARE
GOING TO GET RID OF WHAT IS THE
LIFEBLOOD OF OUR ECONOMY, THE
GREEN NEW DEAL IS 94 PLUS
TRILLION DOLLARS IN TEN YEARS.
LEADING FELONS VOTE, ABOLISHING
I.C.E., NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
CALIFORNIA, ILLINOIS, PICK OFF
FUTURE, STACKING THE
SUPREME COURT WITH LIBERAL
ACTIVIST JUDGES, REPARATIONS,
CRIPPLING THE SECOND AMENDMENT,
THEY WANT A 70% TOP RATE ON
INDIVIDUALS, MARGINAL RATE.
90% ON CORPORATIONS.
NOT MANY PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
INVEST IN AMERICA.
AND IT GOES ON.
AND MAYBE YOU WANT TO DISMISS
ALL THIS, MAYBE YOU WANT TO
LAUGH AT ALL OF THIS IS JUST
CRAZY, UNHINGED MADNESS, BUT
THESE ARE REALLY IDEAS WITHIN
THE NEW RADICAL SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY HAVE, WHAT?
OVER 100 CONGRESS AND SENATORS
SUPPORTING OCASIO-CORTEZ'S NEW
DEAL?
THESE ARE IDEAS THAT HAVE BEEN
TRIED AND HAVE BEEN A MASSIVE
FAILURE EVERYWHERE THEY HAVE
BEEN TRIED.
IF YOU HAVE ANY DOUBTS, LOOK AT
THE PROMISES OF OBAMACARE.
KEEP HER DOCTOR AND PAY LESS,
HOW DID THAT WORK OUT?
TREMENDOUS HUMAN SUFFERING.
LET'S GO TO SAN FRANCISCO.
OH, WE SENT OUR OWN LAWRENCE
JONES BACK YESTERDAY AND HAVE
EXCLUSIVE FOOTAGE JUST AHEAD,
BUT HAVE TO GIVE A VIEWER
WARNING, IT IS PRETTY DISTURBING
WHAT IS GOING ON IN
NANCY PELOSI'S BACKYARD.
BY THE WAY, WITHIN WALKING
DISTANCE TO BOTH HER HOME AND
OFFICE, HOMELESSNESS, NEEDLES,
MASSIVE WEALTH INEQUALITY,
SANCTUARY CITIES, DAY IN AND DAY
OUT, AND YES, FECES.
WE'VE GOT THE VIDEO, ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
THAT IS WHY SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
FLEEING PLACES LIKE CALIFORNIA,
NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY, ILLINOIS,
WHERE ALL OF THESE PROGRESSIVE
FAIRY TALES TURN OUT TO BE
NIGHTMARES COME TO LIFE AND WHY
DO DEMOCRATS MAKE SUCH A FAR
LEFT TURN?
WHERE THE OUT OF TOUCH WITH
LAW-ABIDING, COMMON SENSE
AMERICANS THAT MAKE THIS COUNTRY
GREAT?
WHY EXPLOIT PEOPLE'S INNATE,
NATURAL FEAR THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO TAKE AWAY EVERY FEAR THAT
THEY HAVE AND TAKE CARE OF
EVERYTHING, PROMISES OF
EVERYTHING FOR THREE?
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE!
THEY WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO
DELIVER IT.
IT IS BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS,
THEY ARE BEING LED BY A NEW CROP
OF RADICAL LEFTISTS.
THIS IS THEIR POWER BASE.
THEY MAKE YOU DEPENDENT, YOU
REELECT THEM, THEN YOU ARE
VOTING BACK IN THE VERY BENEFITS
THEY ARE PROMISING TO GIVE YOU.
ESTABLISHMENT DEMOCRATS, EVEN AS
BAD AS THEY ARE, THEY ARE EVEN
TERRIFIED NOW OF LOSING TO THE
FAR LEFT BASE THAT THEY WANT TO
WIN REELECTION.
THEY ARE LITERALLY RUNNING ON
THOSE PROGRAMS.
IT IS WHY EXTREMIST LIKE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, I DIDN'T
MISSPEAK, ARE LEADING THE PARTY.
PELOSI IS REALLY SPEAKER IN NAME
ONLY.
EVERY DAY SHE SOMEHOW FINDS A
WAY TO TOP HER PREVIOUS BAD IDEA
WITH ONE THAT IS EVEN WORSE.
THE LATEST, DISMISSING EFFORTS
BY THE PRESIDENT TO REFORM THE
VA SYSTEM TO HELP OUR VETS,
SAYING EVERYTHING IS FINE.
THANKFULLY, THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN FIXING IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO THE VA, MY
PARENTS TOLD ME GROWING UP THAT
IF IT AIN'T BROKE, DON'T FIX IT.
THE IDEA THAT THIS HAS GROWN,
THIS THING THAT PROVIDES QUALITY
CARE TO OUR VETERANS, SOMEHOW WE
NEED TO OPTIMIZE IT, TINKER WITH
IT UNTIL WE DON'T EVEN RECOGNIZE
IT.
>> Sean: IT IS NOT JUST A
SPEAKER OCASIO-CORTEZ, HER
RADICAL COHORT, CONGRESSWOMAN
OMAR, WHO BY THE WAY, AGAIN
EMBROILED IN SCANDAL.
REMEMBER, FIRST IT WAS A SERIES
OF ANTI-SEMITIC REMARKS.
BY THE WAY, WHAT BERNIE SAID
LAST NIGHT ABOUT ISRAEL, A
DOWNRIGHT DISGRACE FOR EVERY
DEMOCRAT.
DOWNPLAYING, IN THIS CASE,
CONGRESSMAN OMAR, 9/11 TERRORIST
ATTACKS, NOW IT HAS BEEN
REVEALED AT THE MINNESOTA
CONGRESSWOMAN ATTACKED THE
SOLDIERS THAT DIED FIGHTING IN
THE 1993 BLACK HAWK DOWN
OPERATION, POSTING IN A TWITTER
THREAD OH, ABOUT 19 U.S.
SOLDIERS DYING IN THE BATTLE OF
MOGADISHU "IN HIS SELECTIVE
MEMORY, HE FORGETS TO ALSO
MENTION THE THOUSANDS OF SOMALIS
KILLED BY AMERICAN FORCES THAT
DAY."
#NotTodaySatan ."
WHERE IS THAT ACCOUNTABILITY,
THE OUTRAGE?
WHERE THE DEMOCRATIC LEADERS?
THIS IS THEIR PARTY.
AND WHERE IS THE MEDIA IN THIS
COUNTRY?
IF THIS WAS A REPUBLICAN, THEY
WOULD HAVE GONE INSANE RIGHT
NOW, BUT WE ARE HERE TO DO THE
WORK THE MEDIA DOESN'T DO, AND
THAT IS TO EXPOSE HOW RADICALS
AND HOW RADICAL THIS PARTY HAS
BECOME.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND SIMPLE,
BASIC, FUNDAMENTAL THINGS LIKE
THE LAW, THE CONSTITUTION,
SEPARATE OF POWERS, COEQUAL
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT, OR ANY
OF THE REAL CONSEQUENCES OF
THEIR ACTIONS LIKE THE GREEN NEW
DEAL, WHICH COMRADE BILL
DE BLASIO, HERE'S RAMPING UP IN
NEW YORK CITY, CAN'T WAIT FOR
THIS TO HAPPEN, WANTING TO TAKE
THE CITY BACK TO THE STONE AGE,
THAT IS FRED FLINTSTONE FOR
THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE YOUNG AT
HOME, WITH BILL de BLASIO'S
FACE ON IT, WITH "INEFFICIENT
STEEL AND GLASS SKYSCRAPERS,"
BECAUSE THEY'RE BAD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
SO WHAT EXACTLY DOES BILL
DE BLASIO WANT TO BUILD WITH?
I GUESS WE CAN'T USE TREES
BECAUSE THAT WOULD PILLAGE THE
FOREST.
TO DO DEMOCRATS NOT UNDERSTAND
THAT THESE MATERIALS THEY WANT
TO BAND, ALONG WITH OIL AND GAS,
FOSSIL FUELS, IT IS THE LIFEBLOD
OF OUR ECONOMY AND EVERY ECONOMY
AROUND THE GLOBE, IT DRIVES
WAGES AND OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY, IT
IS WHY WE ARE PUTTING THIS BIG
NEW GREEN NEW DEAL DISASTER ON
TRIAL.
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS WANT TO ROLL
BACK ALL OF THE SUCCESS OF THE
TRUMP AGENDA.
ARE YOU BETTER OFF THAN YOU WERE
TO END A HALF YEARS AGO?
IF THE ANSWER IS OBVIOUSLY YES,
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE, WE ARE NOW
ENERGY INDEPENDENT IN AMERICA
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS.
NOT RELYING ON COUNTRIES THAT
HATE OUR GUTS FOR THE LIFEBLOOD
OF OUR ECONOMY, AND NOW WE ARE
NET EXPORTER OF ENERGY.
DID YOU SEE THIS?
FORECASTERS ARE REVISITING THEIR
FIRST QUARTER GDP ESTIMATES.
S&P 500, NASDAQ CLOSING AT
RECORD HIGHS.
ALL WHILE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
RECREATE, YOU KNOW, WHAT?
A ERODE THE ENTIRE MIDDLE CLASS,
SEND US BACK TO FRED LYNN
STONE'S ERA?
THE SUCCESS OF THE FORGOTTEN MEN
AND WOMEN, THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
THIS COUNTRY THAT GO TO WORK,
PAY THEIR TAXES, OBEY THE LAWS,
RAISE THEIR KIDS, REALLY?
THEY ARE GETTING GUARANTEED FROM
THEM?
I DON'T THINK SO.
IT IS GOING TO BE COMING FROM
YOUR ABLE-BODIED, HARDWORKING
AMERICANS, WHO THEY ARE CHASING
OUT OF BIG CITIES.
AND IF YOU LEAVE NEW YORK,
NEW JERSEY, CALIFORNIA, GREAT,
DON'T BRING THOSE STUPID
POLICIES WITH YOU WHEN YOU GO TO
TEXAS WITH THE CAROLINAS,
NASHVILLE, TENNESSEE, OR
FLORIDA.
WANT TO BUILD A BETTER FUTURE
FOR YOUR KIDS AND GRANDKIDS, THE
ENTRE MATERIAL SPIRIT, THE
FREEDOM TO FIND WHAT YOU ARE
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFE
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFC
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFM
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFE
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFY
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFU
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFR
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFG
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFD
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFV
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFN
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFT
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFL
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIFN
MADE TO DO, YOUR PURPOSE IN LIF,